keith is with us Keith's in Phoenix
hi Keith how are you I'm doing great
Dave thanks for taking my call it's an
honor to be able to speak to you you too
how can I help
well I got laid off so about three four
years ago got a buyout of my pension and
my 401k and all that good stuff and
honestly thanks to Financial Peace
University when you get laid off and you
only have a house payment things are a
little bit easier that way sure uh so uh
my thing is is I you know I my father
left us a few rental properties that I
manage for the family and you know I'm
looking for I have this 401k money that
I've put into a self-directed 401 K
because I like real estate well when I
sit down with Realtors and go hey I'm
looking for a property you know they
show me things you know hey invest three
hundred thousand you'll make three to
five percent you know roi after
insurance and hold back for vacancy and
all that stuff and I hear you talking
about twenty and thirty percent return
on investment and when I mention that to
the realtor they're like well yeah buy a
house
leverage it and then buy another one I'm
like whoa I know Dave Ramsey is not
leveraging his real estate so now I'm
not doing cash on cash of twenty percent
I'm talking about an internal rate of
return which incorporates the growth in
value and also incorporates the tax
advantage of owning the property so that
internal internal rate of returns on
residential should be north of fifteen
which involves all three things cash on
cash uh he after all expenses were
averaging about nine okay but but that's
a on the value not on the actually not
on what we paid for it but on the value
of the property we're trying to hit
about nine and what we've got in it
we're probably bumping a little over ten
something like that because we we get in
them right or we don't do them now the
problem when you're buying investment
real estate is this as you know the
money is made at the Buy
so right you get a deal and ninety some
odd percent of Realtors do a great job
at one thing
retailing property you're not in a
retail business you're in the wholesale
business and so you're looking for a
realtor that knows a bargain and is
looking for a bargain looking for a deal
something that's up in foreclosure the
Phoenix market is hot as a firecracker
no pun intended I mean it's it the
market if you know you guys took a dive
with the crash but you've come right
back again screaming back you know I
mean the markets the markets it's not a
good time to buy real estate right now
in that market because it's so hot it's
white-hot and so you're going to have a
hard time digging up deals and that are
making the kind of numbers I'm talking
about
if I were by I'm not buying right this
second because we're working on a campus
that we're pouring all our money into
for this business we're doing a bunch of
big construction big commercial
construction and all its sucking all the
money out so I'm not buying today but I
would have a hard time buying pay okay
so I'm sitting on roughly 300k cash
right now you know waiting for a deal
take your time okay take your own I mean
I can't getting all nervous about
placing that money in something is going
to get you into something at retail and
then yeah you might net you know three
to five percent after expenses that
might be your cash on cash ROI and to me
that's just not acceptable I'd rather
just throw in a good mutual-fund for it
at that okay and all right let's collect
the rent on those yeah yeah lot less
variables and the whether or not your
tenants going to pay or not so yeah I
get exactly so yeah you know if you
I might park a little bit of it if you
want if you really want to try to get it
up above the cat because you're making
1% or something right so if you want to
park a little bit of it into a no load
and let it sit there and make a little
bit you know if you want throw a hundred
grand in there totally beef this up a
little while give you a little patience
but take your time all the money in real
estate is made at the Buy and this is
not a great time to be buying so you're
looking for a needle in the haystack but
doing anything else to go look for it
and you got to find Realtors that aren't
thinking like retailers when you're
buying an investment property you're
looking for realtors that real estate
people that are the know a deal
they got a cash buyer that can close it
by Friday unclosed by Friday I don't
have to qualify or close them by Friday
that I mentioned we can close by Friday
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind